[Musique]
l'esprit de cet esprit d'esprit de
s'affaisser revenu sur la map dont on en
voit de toutes et de toutes les couleurs
et de toutes les goûts de partout dans
le monde
c'est un métro nabeul vedette des
terrasses et des fêtes autour de la
piscine depuis plusieurs années les
cocktails street ont la cote
l'origine du scrutin avant la période
street s'était des autrichiens qui
venaient en italie et en fait quand ils
sont arrivés ils pouvaient pas goûté les
vins
c'était trop puissant au niveau du degré
d'alcool donc les autrichiens disait
sprint se salir ça veut dire allonger
les vins en mettant de l'eau gazeuse en
1912 les frères barbiéri innove avec la
pérol une liqueur d'orange et de jantes
yann une herbe des montagnes qui se
compare aux populaires comme paris mais
en plus sucré et moins amère ajouté au
procès qu un vin mousseux et à de l'eau
gazeuse on obtient la parole stricte et
c'est resté pendant longtemps secret
bien gardé des vénitiens qui étaient les
seuls en bois quand paris est il un
pareil un des pionniers au niveau de ce
qu'on appelle les amères et en fait pour
le phénomène sprit
ils ont fait aussi beaucoup de marketing
je le dois vivre pour pour forcer et
depuis 1,15 en disant on ne voit que ça
exact les ventes de pétrole et autres
boissons à base de gentiane ont connu
une hausse des ventes à la saq de
l'ordre de 60% en menant les
distillateurs du québec ne sont pas en
reste plusieurs ont senti l'engouement
moi je suis port ni tagliani québécois
chu 100% italo québécois et donc on
voulait par des amas airs d'inspiration
italienne qui représentait davantage des
profils de goût et ce qu'elles ont et
familiaux de mario d'amico des
spiritueux et d'iberville et le premier
à avoir flairé la sphère en 2017
il lance alors la mère malade en 2019 la
saq a vendu près de cent mille
bouteilles de cette liqueur amer quand
ne conçu le produit on a troqué un peu
d'amertume mais justement avec des
saveurs qu'on connaît mieux au québec 1
comme comme l'eucalyptus des choses plus
qu'en frais comme les agrumes donc un
petit peu moins d'amertume que matt on
lit les classiques italiens est plus de
savoir qu'on apprécie nous remercions la
vienne écorces d'orange amère
gentiane extrait bien sûr on a une bonne
amertume dans notre produit on ne se
quitte à ce que moins très inquiet quel
compétiteur en jambes
sylvain l'a vu avec l'aperitivo les il
voulait trouver une recette pour se
démarquer la pression ça va être d
essence aux lakers orange écorces de
citron du bar de la baie de genièvre en
croatie prédominant kong ou les îles ont
cru dans le range plus vrai charme
ah oui tu l'as mertzen 8 du sud mais
tout est frais importants pour nous ce
soit pas l'eau au lourd à boire sans
soif est depuis quelques années les
prêts à boire font fureur auprès des
consommateurs l'esprit tu ne font pas
exception avec leur emballage très
coloré et attrayant ils sont parmi les
cinq meilleurs vendeurs des prêts à
boire à la sec
j'adore ça je trouve ça c'est génial
parce que ces nomades ce qu'on retrouve
dans les prêtes à boire
ce sont vraiment des apéros street b en
fait oui ça va être les spreads à la
façon de la maison qui a fait son
aperitivo donc on a plusieurs il y en a
qui sont à base de sites de questions à
base de vin d'autres qui sont déjà en
arômes attisé avec un spiritueux mais
logiquement on se fout supposé rajouter
de quoi on ajustera je rajouter des
glaçons arriver à un goût sembla inspire
ce que ce soit à la maison dans une
formule prête à voir ses poèmes
on voulait s'asseoir expressif appui
remplacer le fait qu'on ne fait pas la
maison avec les ingrédients qu'ont à
portée de main sont simplement bord à
canal ça va être très bon si c'est très
cher mais c'est très frais c'est le
profil est identique à la marmelade
l'apéritif donc ceux qui aimaient se
profile de google vont le retrouver
comme est pas une distorsion dans les
deux formats après on s'attend à quelque
chose qui est pétillât qu'il est donc
quand le bois froid et très pétillant et
ses traits comme léger et souple
nous avons répertorié des frites
prêts-à-boire produits au québec et aux
états unis
tout ça par anaïs et qu ils contiennent
entre 34 et 86 g de sucre au litre et au
taux d'alcool entre 6 et 7%
[Musique]
le premier d'entre eux barefoot donc
américain couleurs super super rose pâle
ça d'avoir osé car la fraise
c'est très léger ouais c'est pas trop
sucré je m'attendais à quelque chose de
très sucré ou non mais j'avais
l'impression sa lettre escrime
on sent l'amertume non c'est très léger
par contre ça je pense que les personnes
qui commencent ou débuts dans le sprint
qui veulent prendre une autre version un
peu plus ronde
je désire leur dirais d'aller est
d'aller là dessus maintenant le deuxième
donc le promet aux ce prix jean lapointe
a déjà j'ai emmené au sahara beaucoup
plus on le sent widgets jean sainvil on
a voté oui
ah ouais c'est plus et plus puissant là
on sent l'alcool bon sens et jean c'est
c'est pas très sucré non plus la couleur
je truc pareil c'est un beau côté rose
et c'est vraiment pas très secret ça non
le troisième prix john donc à base de
cire ont pas encore complètement
ailleurs
on a vraiment le coeur de la bonne si
vous tripes sur le site
ça c'est pour nous mais c'est très
puissant le et ça goûte le rhum je sais
c'est drôle parce que ça goûte la pomme
mais moi je chante toute l'amertume
voilà rangelov zeste d'orange tout on a
ri en bouche vraiment juste à la
personne c'est déjà que les premiers
lacets trois mondes complètement
différents et puis j'aime beaucoup et
l'amertume quatrième donc les îles
l'esprit ce les îles
on est loin de la rue bar mois déjà
c'est la rhubarbe c'est ce genre humain
- l'amertume et une présente quand même
plus par rapport aux autres c'est
celui-là tu montes d'une coche là on
arrive plus dans aperitivo maignan côté
sucré aussi ben oui qui postent sa
troupe sur qui tu l'as mertzen oui oui
c'est chaud que ses bienfaits de la neva
le spritz tonka marmelade jo niveau de
la couleur
les deux derniers se ressemblent pas
même si tu regardes entre l'esprit de
ces îles et la marmelade a sonné ça c
est bien aussi c'est très arbres rescrit
de lys j'aurais envie de dire
alors on l'a de l'amertume mais pas tant
que ça je m'attendais à avoir plus c'est
très beau et si koné très fins
oui c'est très délicat t pareil
j'aimerais ça bien glacé là honnêtement
il ya juste la glace a rajouté voir ça
bien frais
car si c'est vraiment plaisant comme
beaucoup de prêts à boire si vous
insistez pour faire votre propre
cocktail spitz vous avez le choix de
l'aperitivo qui viennent d'italie ou du
québec
un succès sur donc vraiment très simple
à refaire à la maison ça sent l'été
cheers